what is up there reject nation so uh i
saw like the 15 second trailer that came
out a few days ago for this and i really
don't know much about it unreal engine 5
i hear the graphics are nuts on this
they approach lana wachowski to get
involved and i hear keanu reeves and
carry on moss so this is called what the
matrix awakens it's a game
it's an insane experience here it's a
real experience matrix has dipped their
toe in games before the matrix itself
has had visuals inspired from like anime
and games before and the matrix was my
favorite movie of all time yeah we're
gonna watch the full 15 close to 15
minute one that is released on the ign
channel i'm really excited to check this
out i really don't know much about it
here he goes this is gonna be fun
[Music]
i hope this looks exactly like answer
the matrix
deja vu
[Music]
called 2021 the return of the matrix
[Music]
hi
i'm thomas anderson
like many of you i work with computers
i like the freedom i feel outside the
limitations of the real world
but computers are also mirrors
we're looking back on what we are and
the choices we make
the worlds we build
they also confront us with questions
about why we want to choose this over
that
why we want to make x instead of a y
where do ideas of who we are and what we
want even come from
you take the red pill
and i show you how deep the rabbit hole
goes
this isn't real
what is real
how do you define real
for instance i'm not even sure why i'm
here
i remember waking up and thinking that
i'm supposed to come here
that it was important for me to ask she
animated it okay how do we know what is
real is that real or not
no it's unreal hi
i'm keanu reeves
over 20 years that looks like a real one
in an industry where actors have tried
to remain perpetually young
we wondered whoa
hi
i'm carrie anne moss and i play trinity
in the matrix films 20 years ago we
asked ourselves how long it would be
before faces and bodies could be changed
as easily as we change clothes
we wondered what would identity mean in
their completely digital world
and what would reality mean
when a world we can build feels as real
as our own
holy [ __ ]
this is
what they wanted
they were fine with your theoretical
mumbo jumbo but you needed some sexy
action
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
welcome to the matrix
how are you doing back there
sorry i was told this is a sim preparing
me to fight the system
right now
all right
yeah
it's all supposed to be a little
word of unreal
agents are bad
but whatever you do stay the hell away
from marketing
awesome
so
what now
how could you ever watch the video
shoot the tires
say no more
oh wow they've done it they made a real
matrix game
imagine this in an oculus or something
like that
oh my god
never wanted to do the freeway fight now
never wanted next-gen system more than i
do right now
oh my god
these dumb agents keep standing on the
roof on the if you try to guard him
help
[Laughter]
whoa
[Music]
i need a roof
now we're in the french connection
holy crap
holy crap
no
oh my god
wow
wow
[Music]
so are you
[Music]
my hands can feel it i know
[Music]
my power character is not worried about
getting shot
it's like a real action movie brought to
life it's a matrix man
this is great
this is gonna be one of the best video
movie adaptations in the gaming
[Music]
nice
destruction
reminiscent of reloaded in a lot of ways
[Music]
unreal indeed
bravo
come a long way since the first engine
[Music]
whoa
huh
wow it's like you can control the matrix
yeah
god of your own world
just a different wow
it's the different qualities of light
and everything
it's beautiful
[Music]
wow
i wish you could see it in like neo's
vision yeah this is all the code
yeah
that should be a cheat you can play in
matrix vision
fly
oh yeah why why would you walk anywhere
ouch
change the sun rotation
all right i want no crowd no traffic no
parked cars
[Laughter]
wow
so it is just a like an open world
experience it's not like a storyline
here
i guess
i mean you're giving way too much
controls it'd be kind of difficult to
create a storyline around it yeah so you
just kind of
explore the matrix and get into fights
now imagine this applied to web slinging
this would be an incredible vr
experience oh yeah man
stem also showcases an experimental
night lighting mode
using only emissions wow
wow
oh my god
so real
that looks like very genuine like very
realistic night lighting
this is too much control
this is the real matrix
[Music]
unreal driver and real driving
although i do admire whoever's got the
joystick right now is trying to stay in
the lakes
wow uh
seven million plus assets can you go in
the water
no you die immediately
matrix even they cannot handle water
missions
wow this player's obsessed with sun
rotation
i need the perfect lighting at all times
[Laughter]
you control the sky
look at that detail of the building the
sun reflecting off them
that guy just coded out
hit the cop yeah
[Laughter]
rotate that sun
rotate that sun yeah if you rotate it
enough times in the right directions
it's a cheat code
is there a function to increase the
green tint
so is this the version of seeing the
code
i guess so
seeing each asset it's its own glowing
brick
wow
i just want to play in this mode
i think the demo is available
yeah man
for free
smack him
serif
got a good grip on personal space though
where's the woman in the red dress
dude
that was beautiful it was wonderful that
was like dazzling and also like soothing
in a weird way just exploring the matrix
and changing the light and exploring all
the different assets it seems like the
perfect matrix game there's been a few
major schemes happening there matrix
online enter the matrix path of neo yeah
yeah
this seems like the perfect one the
level of control that you have because
the matrix itself is a computer this
seems like the great blend of
controlling a computer that you get to
be in
and it brings it visually realizes that
i don't know i i guess there's no story
to it i just have no idea i haven't
looked it up i mean i feel yeah it's
like i don't know really either i feel
like it would have to have some element
of story just because you know the
wachowskis love to make auxiliary
companion pieces to the movies and and
you know have the lore expand outward i
wonder if it's going to be complementary
towards the matrix resurrections i would
imagine because the other games are
canon towards the matrix trilogy so
which would mean that they are canonical
towards the matrix resurrection the
matrix resurrection seems to also be
doing some real meta stuff with its own
franchise the fact that they had the
intro here with keanu reeves and carrie
anne moss breaking in as themselves as
as the personalities and talking about
like we have to leave with the actions
of the marketing yeah you know we want
some sexy instead of all the theoretical
mumbo jumbo yeah like
having the self-awareness there which
seems like the matrix resurrection is
going to be applying as well i wonder
how much if that's going to tie in
because this was in development around
the same time the conception of matrix
resurrections was occurring this is it
just seems like the perfect time to
because now technology is finally caught
up to the point where it's like it's
there's still moments yeah yeah it's
like you can still tell at times when
it's like you know you cut inside the
car and okay that's the cgi keanu reeves
because he's much younger obviously but
like the shades on it looks good it's so
good
because one thing games when they try to
bring celebrities faces into it the
thing that really they often miss it's
that polar express effect the damn eyes
yeah
it's the dead eyes it's really hard to
bring that to life especially when you
are trying to duplicate an actual
person's face so that's what i would
show i was like oh it's in the eyes but
when they have the shades on it looks
pretty damn real man right yeah for a
movie and a lore that's all about
bending reality and stuff like that yeah
just i don't know if this is in any kind
of vr or oculus it seems like the the
closer we get with all that tech the
more it is just going to feel like the
actual matrix yes
i loved it i absolutely loved it and uh
i just got ps5 a little unboxing that i
did for the ps5 that i got to show you
guys so now i can download it your lucky
duck oh [ __ ] i never wanted a next-gen
console more than this moment
well guys what do you think about the
footage leave your thoughts down below i
can't wait to rotate the sun it's the
main thing i got from this oh yeah and
then turn it out entirely just watch all
the lights come on session with sun
rotation but fighting the agents and
stuff because the
gameplay matrix game brought the like
bullet time to life and everything this
is a whole other beast right here
you got all kinds of action set pieces
and then on top of that you just got to
live in the matrix and like a true open
world which is yeah that's the perfect
format for this all right gang leave
your thoughts down below are you going
to get yourself a steak while sitting
across the table of an agent
we'll see you guys soon